do you ever bolt awake at midnight in
the cold sweat and wonder what happened
to the announce Shin Megami Tensei Fire
Emblem crossover to have sudden
realizations that cyberpunk 2077 and
scalebound
are things that exist to even remember
that we're getting a new crackdown a new
Gears of War and a new phantom dust here
are some of the games that have fallen
out of the spotlight but not out of our
hearts games that are confirmed to be in
development but that have been silent
for a while
two years ago Nintendo dropped a
bombshell during its first video
presentation of the year Atlas and Fire
Emblem developer intelligent systems
were teaming up for in Megami Tensei
Fire Emblem crossover thinking would
feature characters from both series the
trailer showing characters from the
franchise's first games all the way up
to recent ones including shin megami
tensei 4 and Fire Emblem awakening fans
appetites were wet and that was it we've
heard nothing from either company in the
game since besides small reassurances
that yes it is still in development
rumors began circulating on 4chan late
last year that the game had been
cancelled due to conflicting viewpoints
among the teams recently Atlas told
GameSpot that it couldn't comment on the
project status here's to hoping this
drool-worthy collaboration won't go the
way of the Last Guardian at Gamescom
last year Sony showed cryptic footage of
people screaming then encouraged
PlayStation 4 owners to go download
something called PT less than a day
later one lucky user beat the
complicated and seemingly random mini
horror title to discover a trailer a
trailer for a new Silent Hill game made
by Kojima Productions with input from
famed film director Guillermo del Toro
and star Norman Reedus
think about that for a second a new
Silent Hill game made by Kojima and del
Toro starring Darrell from The Walking
Dead
it's the perfect confection of
visionaries to make a poopy pants
survival horror game but since that
trailer in its playable teaser we've
heard nothing just the endless shrieks
of those replaying PT to mine its
secrets silent hill's as the game is
called has no release date and no
information other than it exists
and when contacted for comment Kaname
told us that there's nothing new to
share right now we're not expecting to
see this one anytime soon
we all knew more Kingdom Hearts was
coming when the seventh sequel didn't
wrap up the storyline officially
announced at e3 2013 Kingdom Hearts 3
will theoretically wrap up the current
storyline
although Square Enix says this won't be
the last game in the franchise
technically we've known about the game
since 2010 when then director Tetsuya
Nomura acknowledged that the game was
coming in an interview published in a
guidebook the game is coming to
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one making it the
first Kingdom Hearts on a Microsoft
console right after e3 2013 however
Nomura admitted that maybe Kingdom
Hearts 3 had been announced too early
why because it's a way too early in
development there's no way we'll see it
soon right
not in 2015 anyway based on how little
we've seen so far but we have seen is
interesting attacks based on Disney
theme park attractions throwing some
worlds based on Pixar Marvel and Star
Wars properties and I'm sold
last false granik's announced that
Nomura had stepped away from Kingdom
Hearts 3 to work full time on Final
Fantasy 15 another mystical unicorn and
squares development bag with the new
director focused on the project it's
looking a little more likely we'll get
it sooner than later
if sooner comes after later that is and
according to co-director Tai yasue a
will hear more about Kingdom Hearts 3
including just what's up with those
attractions and transforming keyblades
this year phantom dust phantom dusts 10
years later we're getting a phantom dust
reboot according to Microsoft who
announced the game as an Xbox one
exclusive at e3 2014 we're getting an
update on the classic with new gameplay
and graphics last fall Phil Spencer said
we'd likely hear more about the game
this year probably at e3 that's
literally all we know but guys were
getting another phantom dust phantom
does Microsoft's e3 2014 press
conference was able Oh out of
announcements in addition to phantom
dust the company announced a new
crackdown was in development with
original director Dave Jones at the head
the new crackdown is aiming to blend its
single-player campaign with co-op
multiplayer making it a seamless
experience now we haven't seen any art
or design work since that e3 trailer so
it's hard to tell where exactly this
game is in development like phantom dust
Phil Spencer said it's safe to say we'll
hear more about crackdown this year
for a release date we're not betting on
adding these to our libraries in 2015
this game oh man
the third big surprise to come from that
fateful Microsoft III press conference
was scalebound scalebound is in
development with Platinum Games the
studio behind Bayonetta which means
we're going to get something good
scalebound a sort of remission of Panzer
Dragoon but also not players will run up
against formidable creatures and tether
their fate to a dragon whose skills you
can borrow for armor scale Val looks
incredibly ambitious and again there has
been no new game information since the
announcement however recently Microsoft
Studios creative director Ken LOB's said
that we'd be able to play scalebound
later this year site we're getting a new
Gears of War we know this because one
year later in January 2014 Microsoft
announced that it had acquired the
rights to the Gears of War IP and
developer black tusk studios was
currently chugging away at a new one
Microsoft also snagged one Rod Fergusson
the producer on all previous Gears of
War games to head the endeavor our new
Gears won't be a reboot and will launch
only for Xbox one one of those nibbling
side effects of being a Microsoft
exclusive
we've reached out to Microsoft to ask
what's up with phantom dust crackdown
sky bone and Gears of War but the
company offered no new information at
this time everyone relax we're thinking
III will be the sweet spot for new info
on these games we've seen next to
nothing from this Bandai Namco Capcom
crossover and heard even less as the
second crossover between the companies
the first being Street Fighter cross
Tekken 2nd cross street fighter will use
Tekken's 3d fighting style at the time
the title was announced for PlayStation
3 and Xbox one way way back in the
heyday of the previous console
generation as of spring 2012 Tekken
cross Street Fighter was ten percent
complete according to tech and producer
Katsuhiro Harada and at San Diego
comic-con last year Harada promised the
game hadn't been cancelled it was just
taking some more time to cook he told
fans please relax
Patel can be relaxed when Street Fighter
cross Tekken was awesome and we still
managed to get it in a bunch of Street
Fighter 4 update since the announcement
kept Khan said they want to finish
Tekken 7 and all its planned updates
before they can talk Tekken cross Street
Fighter but goodness knows how long that
is going to take whimsical little number
rhyme was announced during Gamescom 2013
doing a flurry of indie game reveals at
Sohn
press-conference rhyme is an adventure
game influenced by hayao miyazaki movies
Shadow of the Colossus and ICO which
means it immediately captured the
imagination of those watching that first
trailer the game is about a boy trying
to escape an island in a curse and
that's really sweet but it's all
developer tequila works is shared crimes
will be a PlayStation 4 exclusive and
according to tequila works is set to
release sometime in 2015
whatever you do don't call it Mirror's
Edge to the new Mirror's Edge will be a
prequel not a sequel to the 2008
original until the origin story of
protagonist faith the game was rumoured
to be in development for years until EA
announced dice was working on it at e3
2013 the game will focus on up close and
personal first-person combat and it
looks like we'll be running our little
hearts out across rooftops again after
being a no-show at e3 2014 we begin to
wonder just how close we were to getting
the actual game
sure enough directly following me is
Mirror's Edge less press conference dice
posted a note to the game's official
website decoding the title had a long
way to go it will me sta what was up
with the game they just said rockin and
rollin keep the faith huh if you're into
games Cliff Bleszinski is practically a
household name after leaving Epic Games
in 2012 after 20 years of service
Lozinski skipped off into the sunset of
retirement his vacation from games were
short-lived and in summer 2014 it was
revealed that he was working on a new
game called blue streak at his newly
founded studio boskie productions blue
streak will be a free-to-play sci-fi
themed arena shooter and will be
published by mega company Nexon for PC
Lozinski recently told GameSpot that the
studio is playing the game on a daily
basis now and closing in on a file name
for the title the game will feature
multiple modes arenas attacks and
abilities and the team is now
experimenting with a few different
styles of movement it'll be interesting
to see where cliffy B goes after jazz
jackrabbit and Gears of War and we've
been anxiously awaiting news on this
title CD Projekt RED announced cyberpunk
2077 in May 2012 based on the cyberpunk
tabletop role-playing games by Mike pon
Smith's cyberpunk 2077 would be a mature
role playing game geared towards a more
adult audience in case that wasn't
evident by the cyborg lady doing the
splits and her skivvies in the only
promotional materials originally
announced as cyberpunk the game was
given its 2077
had later that year with a trailer
arriving a few months later and
suggestions that it would be a
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one game but in
March 2014 CD Projekt RED announced the
highly anticipated The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt would be delayed from fall of that
year to early 2015 and then again just
recently the studio delayed The Witcher
2 may at the time of the first delay
cyberpunk 2077 s development was said to
not be affected but this time we heard
nothing when asked what was up CD
Projekt RED told GameSpot that it had
nothing to say about cyberpunk 2077 and
would remain mom until The Witcher 3 is
release the Sony Online Entertainment
live Expo and 2013 brought with it the
announcement of EverQuest next to the
next swell EverQuest technically we knew
about the game in 2009 when Sony hinted
that we were definitely getting more
EverQuest after EverQuest 2 then the
company said we weren't only getting a
new EverQuest butt EverQuest next
landmark a creation focused standalone
game thing that would allow users to
craft bits and pieces for the world
landmark went into alpha in January 2014
into beta in March and that is where it
has remained ever quest next and next
landmark will come to PC and likely ps4
but when is still up in the air
recently SOE told GameSpot they are
preparing for Landmarks open beta phase
which will launch realistically soon and
will then move into full time work and
EverQuest next main content here's to
hoping we see more of these games in
2015 and dare I say some final releases